we have this in this tweet thread Mike
cernovich
to give you the context for those just
tuning in yoel Roth a guy who claimed
Trump was a Nazi head of safety says we
are staying Vigilant against attempts to
manipulate conversations about the 2022
midterms read on for independent
analysis of our team's work
unfortunately we can't because I'm
blocked by a person I don't know that's
ideological neutrality I guess a Elon
Elon Musk responded saying he's working
with these grievance organizations but
this woman whose Twitter account I can't
see because I am blocked is Renee
diresta Mike cernovich points out Renee
diresta is the director of research at
cyber security company new knowledge and
head of policy at the non-profit data
for democracy new knowledge got caught
buying Russian Bots to follow Roy Moore
on Twitter during the 2018 midterms it's
an odd source to rely on for an
independent analysis of the 2020 2022
midterms
so uh where's the rest of Mike's tweets
why are they breaking it up like that's
kind of weird
they did that anyway Mike cernovich goes
on to point out for some reason
Twitter's not loading it that's
fascinating I guess
there we go when Russian Bots began
following Roy Moore in 2017 it was
treated as a huge as a huge National
story Moore was mocked for blaming
Democrats yes Democrats bought the Bots
and hoaxed the Willing press now someone
who works for new knowledge the same
firm is on 2022 integrity that's
actually actually sounds
basically as bad as the DHS conspiring
with Twitter to manipulate elections
Elon Musk is now actively working with
an organization that manipulated the
elections to help Democrats okay
so I mean I'm sorry guys if it's if it's
a bit you know it's a black pilling or
whatever you want to say it's
pessimistic
it's what's happening I'm what do you
think Miles about this will this impact
your use of of Twitter how do you think
Elon what do you how do you think Elon
is doing here oh yeah I've got no backup
I'm completely screwed on social media
if it goes south but truthfully I never
really had faith on Elon Musk because
he's in bed with these people these
corporations and really powerful people
no matter what like a culture we
pressured into it otherwise you'll be
kicked out of a circle and everything
collapses behind you like a sand castle
When the tide comes in these these
people are not living in reality are
they they don't understand how things
work how Society works and also how a
platform like this works and no matter
what like Tim said these people are
children they're gonna throw a fit until
everything collapses apart now I just
really hope Elon Musk gets to a point
where he gets so upset he just doubles
down and just says hey guys it's gonna
be a right-wing Utopia right-wing in
quotations and then those people will
realize that they're screaming and whiny
will not do anything and then from there
something is actually built something
better for a future where we can invest
knowing that our Free Speech will be
upheld but I don't see it happening I'm
pessimistic but I guess we just can't
let go and roll out and see what the
time says it's beyond just the walk left
screaming though I mean true this is
election interference this is Elon Musk
colluding with an organization that
interfered in the 2018 midterms to help
Democrats win as they're bragging how
they're going to have control of this
upcoming midterm election they're
literally saying hey the same people
that did this we're the same guys who
are going to be watching what's going to
be happening in the upcoming midterm and
they're bragging about it that that's
like that's mud in your face that that's
absolute absolutely disrespectful and as
you mentioned miles again yeah he has a
lot of government contracts he does a
lot of business with China and with that
comes a lot of pressure because when
you're working with the government
that's giving you a lot of money the
government could say we're going to give
you a little bit less you know those
satellites you know those spaceships you
know maybe we don't want to finance you
maybe we don't want to do this if you
all do this or do this or do this for us
uh musk also you know promoted World
Government before he's a transhumanist
he supported the vaccines carbon tax a
universal basic income so a lot of the
policies that he puts forward should be
obviously questioned since I would say
they go along with an agenda that is
very questionable as well yeah it lines
up a little bit with the world economic
Forum yeah a little bit too much I like
that the guy likes memes I like that he
triggered a lot of these people all
those are not positives and there is
there was a republican I think in
Arizona who got suspended Elon said
looking into it and the guy got
reinstated so we don't know for a fact
Elon did that there are net positives
here I don't want to come out and just
be like the end is nigh and elon's
terrible I think there's bad things he's
doing and we need to tell him we will
not tolerate it so he's coming out and
saying oh everybody's mad at me he's
like the left and the right are both mad
at me and it's like dude
who do you think is going to pay the
money the left hates you they've always
hated you and they're quitting the
platform and lying about you they're
coming out saying since Elon took over
hates gotten substantially worse despite
the fact that elon's team has said no
we've actually been policing these are
bot accounts and we're getting rid of
them
doesn't matter Democrats are coming out
and saying that he's charging eight
dollars for free speech maybe Elon must
learn that these people are whiny babies
that will never be satisfied unless you
give them everything and if you're not
willing to give them everything then you
need to tell them to go bye-bye there's
there's the room you can go hang out and
play by yourself go to your other social
media network but they're not going to
be here they're never going to be
satisfied oh exactly and the thing is
too these these big leftist accounts
most of them are Bots anyway they have
no real following in the real worlds on
paper maybe yes but Elon has to Remember
at the end of the day the right-wing
people are the ones that actually are
supporting him like you said and if we
get behind him and rally him to actually
do the right thing things will come
together
at the end of the Devo
um
I think things are screwed I think Elon
Musk is going to crumble he's going to
give in what do you guys think what
about 750 Elon okay can we do 750 I'm
just I'm just joking
I'd pay 20 bucks yeah he's offering up
for Twitter a suite of of Premium tools
and it does help get rid of bots all
that I'm totally down for that I do
think he should be paying top craters
which he also announced is in the is in
the pipeline but I'm not going to give
any money until he frees the political
prisoners I'm not going to spend money
on a platform that sucks and Twitter
sucked for a long time I barely care
about it I post garbage nonsense memes
like advocating for war and neutering
children come on or is taking the advice
and policies from the people that made
it suck and are going to make it suck
that much more which he's bragging about
today which again it's still early a lot
of people are arguing like Hey we're
still not even a week in here let's give
him time let's see what happens here but
I think during this time I think we're
at a crucial point where we need to hold
his feet to the fire we need to
criticize him whenever he Goofs up I
think this was a major goof up I think
this also highlights a major problem
moving forward that could be very
significant for the prospects of free
speech and I'm willing to pay twenty
dollars I'm willing to pay a hundred
dollars if we have free speech these
organizations that he's working with
don't support free space and that's a
big problem it's funny Elon did say he
bought Twitter to help save Humanity
right yep what if what if his plan is to
destroy it because you know Twitter is
just bad well he's got the spaceships
too he's playing to leave it and start
his own Humanity I guess you never know
you mean destroy Twitter not destroy
Earth yeah yeah well it's the same time
left his eyes you know oh you might
destroy everything he buys Twitter and
then disassembles it and gives the parts
out to the the masses it's brilliant
that's exactly what he should do that'd
be amazing honestly if just like ah I
would I would love to see it you know
too many people tie their net worth
their their personal self-worth to their
Twitter accounts their verification
badges their following and all that
stuff and I'm just like
we need to take a figurative bucket full
of ice water and splash it in somebody's
face
there are too many people that look at
this and they're like it's all I have I
would I would I would laugh if I woke up
and Twitter was just gone and when you
go to twitter.com it's a picture of Elon
Musk giving a thumbs up saying Twitter
was bad for you from the get from the
get-go so suck it I'd be like yeah or
the Doge the dog Doge dog oh I got my uh
my Twitter shares I got cashed out um
the money appeared in my account so
you're indulge now I just put it all in
Dosh it's not not a bad idea I've got
about 6 500 doge coins sitting there in
the wings because I think doge is
essentially going to be Twitter stock
you know I'm I'm optimistic about this
because Elon essentially purchased
Twitter off of BlackRock he bought it
away from the global cartels the
international you know Mega corpse and
now he's taking it private or it's about
to become private I don't know if it's
technically off the public market now is
it already that's probably done now it's
private yeah so we talked about the
negative let's talk about some of the
positives here because I I got we got to
be honest here there are some things to
be optimistic about like Ian mentioned
here there there still is a prospect
there is still a possibility that a lot
of people could be brought back and
let's talk about some of the positives
here vivofray has been brought back he
didn't have to admit he was wrong to get
his account back he got his account back
that was right a republican running in
Arizona I think got his account back
without having to apologize he's
responding to individuals that were hurt
by the platform before wrongly and
saying don't worry I'll fix this just
give me some time if you're optimistic
if you want to believe in him and have
faith in him sure believe in him uh
there's also uh the interaction he had
with AOC today which was absolutely
hilarious and the White House fact
checked which is absolute gold and no no
I'm not giving him credit for the White
House fact check because that already
was happening before him the the
community I knew what was happening to
Donald Trump no but it was it was
happening across the board well before
Elon Musk took over it's just we're in
election season and they've made some
mistakes but I haven't noticed it before
this this AOC thing is funny she said
LMAO at a billionaire earnestly trying
to sell people on the idea that free
speech is actually eight dollars an
eight dollars a month subscription plan
you see uh you know Elon responded your
feedback is appreciated now pay eight
dollars Elon she's lying when did anyone
say that free speech is eight bucks no
free speech is free you can get a free
account on Twitter if you want premium
services that costs money but she's
lying yep I I don't get it does Elon not
get that he these people are are liars
free speeches and free free speech
requires taxes to pay for a military to
guard your borders so that you can say
things without getting shots
free speech exists and it is an inherent
right given by God because we have guns
to defend no that's not true well duh if
we didn't have guns to defend it we'd
get conquered by the CCP and would no
longer have free speeches excuse me hear
me if you're standing in China can you
yell out F the CCP I don't think so well
you can't your mouth this doesn't move
you're like you can but I don't know if
you'll get the last word like in Doctor
Strange when the you know black what
whatever the fork guy whatever his name
is what's that guy you know talking
about he's got the fork or whatever and
then he they're like he could kill you
with one whisper and then she's like
what mouth and he's like yeah that's
what happens when you go to China bro
you can speak it happens what you're
saying is that some people may try and
stop you well I'm saying you don't need
a government for that you like if you're
in the middle of the woods you can say
whatever no I'm talking about legal free
speech like American legal Free Speech
First Amendment stuff is protected by
guns no that's funded by money okay
that's not what Elon Musk is arguing
here Elon Musk is saying specifically
hey AOC you want to use the platform
it's free you don't have to pay eight
dollars for a verified badge he also
went on a tweet storm he tweeted uh some
of her merchandise that's 58 dollars for
a sweater uh he then also posted a bunch
of memes one of them being an NPC
laughing and being really happy smiling
about an eight bucks uh Starbucks latte
and then crying about eight bucks per
month
on Twitter so Props to him being in the
meme game and going against these people
and then willing to stand up for what he
believes in he's also talking about
setting up a video paywall which some uh
news organizations are talking about
could rival adult websites now if that
happens that again is questionable and
that negative for societies this is this
is what a lot of the mainstream media
Publications said that if he offers a
paywall for video he's going to be in
direct competition with the adult
websites who do something very similar
uh that would be again a net negative
since there is a lot of adult content
already on Twitter I think it's 13 or 18
of Twitter is adult content
um and that is a negative and is somehow
allowed which is still weird which they
might arbitrarily use against him in the
future because that's another weak point
of Twitter that somehow is able to do
this and other platforms aren't on the
major app stores that's a good point uh
mines was actually removed from the
Google app store because porn was
showing up on the site on moderated it
was like Hey Twitter has porn what is it
one nipple yeah it was it was something
a name it wasn't a lot and we were
attempting to moderate it but because
there was so much and there were human
moderators and like there were seven of
us or something we couldn't keep up it's
a rigged game man a few things get so
supported someone did Super Chat uh I
believe this is let me see who had the
super chair we normally save him but
somebody good point Bren Bren Ben is
that what it says according to Jeremy
the quartering Elon has to play ball
because there's the Google Play Store
and server factors to keep in mind also
yoel Roth is only there still because he
knows where the bodies are it's fair
point you know so we'll see but Elon
doesn't need to be tweeting this stuff
out to Virtue signal
what's the point like what is is Twitter
going to get banned from the Play Store
why would that happen like just oh you
never know I mean maybe because of
collusion I mean it's happened a few
times
um there's an app called iFunny it was
free speech anyone could say anything it
was actually quite well moderated to
some degree you know nothing dodgy on
there but he got taken off 20 or
something times when something blows up
and leaks outside this app so I think at
some point he may double down just take
it out of the app store or the Play
Store parlor got banned because Donald
Trump was threatening to be on that
platform so we saw a collusion if you
think there's collusion with big Tech
social media there's obviously collusion
with all the big uh app stores obviously
they're also going to be targeting
people politically just like they do on
big Tech social media and this is just
one Avenue and there could be a
possibility here that we have to
entertain of the DHS coming down and be
like we'll take you off the app store
we'll make sure you guys get hit for all
the adult website stuff you have on your
on your thing we'll make sure you guys
get punished uh unless of course you
allow George W bush and its foundation
along with the ADL to decide how we're
going to be playing by the rules here so
that could be happening right now and
that again is another possibility that
is worth considering on the other side
though true social is allowed on the app
store right and everyone hates Trump on
the left right they kicked him off
Twitter but he's on the App Store so
that is hope for Twitter in the end of
the day yeah I think that Google the
transhumanists and the technologists the
technocrats don't really have
they don't play the Left Right Paradigm
they're looking for like the most value
and efficiency out of the system
yeah unfortunately but the DHS like you
said has influence with them and but
that's why you know you know you free
the software code we'll build a
decentralized app store we can make F
Droid go go mainstream it's a little
wild west like you can download an app
that has a virus in it you gotta be
careful in F Droid but it's better than
relying on Google and Apple for our soul
I store Monopoly like we gotta we gotta
break up the the App Store Monopoly
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there